Від неприхованої радості…
"Дуже радісно!"
…байдужості. До повного несприйняття:
Це біда наша, страшна біда
Емоції серед вірян різних конфесій в Україні дуже розбіжні.
після новини про продовження надання томоса українській церкві
та зняття анафеми з патріарха Української православної церкви
Київського Патріархату Філарета
та предстоятеля Української автокефальної церкви Макарія.
Віряни Київського патріархату не стримують радості.
Дуже-дуже. Тому що я постійно ходжу в Київський патріархат,
і всі роки незалежності була прихильницею
тільки цього патріархату.
Для подружжя Єрьоменків цей день - особливий.
Вони з самого ранку прийшли до Володимирського собору  поставити свічку
поставити свічку та помолитися за здоров`я Філарета.
Ми раді, тому вирішили прийти саме сьогодні
до Володимирського кафедрального собору,
де настоятель митрополит Філарет.
Максим з Луганська. Він з віруючої родини,
з дитинства ходив до церкви. Продовжував молитися
і після 2014 року,
коли після окупації рідного міста проросійськими сепаратистами
переїхав до Києва.
Змінив не лише місце проживання, але й церкву.
В Луганську я не звертав уваги, чи це православна церква
Київського чи Московського патріархату.
Але після того, як трапилися події 2014 року,
коли відбулася незаконна анексія Криму Російською Федерацією,
коли  Росія почала агресію проти України на Донбасі,
для мене це стало принциповим питанням.
Саме війна на Сході України змінила ставлення
до Української православної церкви Московського патріархату багатьох вірян,
з якими поспілкувалася DW.
Після початку війни, коли славлять Кирила,
це для будь-якого українця неприємно.
Але зараз молимо Бога, щоби був
об'єднавчий собор і томос для Української церкви.
Позитивні новини для православних Київського патріархату
зовсім інакше сприймають прибічники Московського патріархату,
з якими нам вдалося поспілкуватися.
Вони продовжують називати вірян київського патріархату "розкольниками",
а Патріарха Філарета "злочинцем".
А з рішенням Вселенського патріархату не згодні.
Я не хочу ніякого томоса,
я хочу жити в істинній церкві.
Мало розколу, мало сект в нас?
Ви знаєте, скільки в Україні різних сект і віросповідань?
До миру та злагоди між православними
різних конфесій в Україні закликає Священний Синод.
Адже томос обіцяє створення єдиної української православної церкви,
про яку -незалежно від патріархату та мови -
щодня моляться святі отці.